Oh
Oh
you
1a aspect of the moral and political
theory that Thomas Hobbes is
articulating in Leviathan that a lot of
readers especially first-time readers
tend to find rather puzzling or even
confusing has to do with what we can
call moral conceptions and we're
thinking about moral conceptions we're
thinking about what people often call
moral values in the the broad generic
sense where we're talking about good and
bad right and wrong or even things like
beautiful and uglier honorable and
dishonorable the useful and the harmful
the pleasurable and the painful we're
often in traditional moral theory
brought under those as well because they
can all be understood in terms of
various types of goodness or or
rightness or something along those lines
and you notice that we can't ever escape
that entirely because even if you were
to ask is it good that we talk about
these things or is it good to you know
be very tolerant you're talking about
something that has a moral residence to
it already now when I say that this is
often confusing to readers of Hobbes
what I have in mind is is this there's a
very important break that's going to
take place that we're going to talk
about in one of the later videos that
has to do with what we call the social
contract Hobbs is going to depict the
natural state of humankind as a state in
which we're very prone to conflict with
each other because we not only compete
with each other but we value things in
ways that are different from each other
and he thinks that societies can break
down even if they are functioning
societies they can break down and
devolved into this sort of chaos this
sort of anarchy in terms of moral values
he also writes at many points as if
there aren't really moral values in a
full sense until you have a functioning
civil society that's being regulated
according to the norms that are built
into the social contract
these are moral norms they're not merely
ways to get along there are ways to get
along because that's what scene is being
good for us but then once we have them
in place they come to take on the status
of what we ought to do what is good for
us and there's a basic level of
agreement even if it has to be a forced
agreement in society and Hobbesian
society that the social contract is
providing us so do we have any sort of
moral norms or moral values outside of
the social contract well the answer is
yes and one reason this is again why
it's often confusing i'm going to give
you a clue here this is something I've
done quite a bit of work on myself one
reason why the state of nature is such a
mess according to Hobbes is that it's
not that there's no morality whatsoever
in the state of nature there's too many
competing moralities and even in the
same person we're going to see that they
can't remain consistent and constant
over time so this is a really important
way to sort of like transform how we're
looking at and the key to this is going
to be in these chapters that I'm having
you read chapter nine on the on the
difference of manners and chapter 6 on
the involuntary beginnings of voluntary
motions because there's a couple really
important clues that we're going to find
in there so I've tallied those up here
and I put them under the category of
human being because the Hobbs thinks
that this applies to every one of us
remember Hobbs has this mechanistic
conception our minds are really just
extensions of our bodies you know what's
going on in our brain if you like he
thought the heart had something to do
with it but you know we know that it now
it's really about the brain but the
bodies and continual motion if you have
this materialistic conception of things
the brain itself is in continual motion
that doesn't mean that it's like you
know moving from place to place but what
he means by motion is any sort of
important
change do you think about what your
brain actually is it's this very complex
set of circuits that are you know you
they're made out of cells they're made
out of neurons and those neurons are
constantly firing electrical impulses
back and forth you add to this other
systems like our circulatory system and
a hormonal system and what's going on in
in our you know although the bacteria in
our body and the effects that they're
producing and you have this body that's
in continual flux not only in terms of
its organs that are you know pump the
heart's pumping away but the brain as
well so because our body is in continued
emotion that's going to have some
important of facts when it comes to what
it is that we desire and what it is that
were averse to what we'll get to that in
a moment he says that desires and
aversions themselves are changing over
time we'll come back to that I want to
talk about this thing that he brings up
about there being no final end he ends
up saying this in the section here we go
this is an in chapter chapter 9 of the
difference of manners he says when we're
thinking about the Felicity of this life
Felicity means happiness happiness is
what we're supposed to all be striving
after and in traditional moral theory
was a lot in thought well you know we
may disagree about what happiness looks
like but in general there is some final
and that we're aiming it Plato thought
that there was something like this
Aristotle thought there was something
like this the way Theus did you know
many other thinkers so Hobbs says there
is no such finis ultimus final end the
ultimate the goal that we're all seeking
nor Summum bonum greatest good the good
that would encompass all the other goods
or would you know outweigh it the one
that we want to sacrifice everything
else to get why he's
as well because nothing can retain that
sort of status for us over time why
because we do change in our desires and
aversions because our body is changing
over time so not only can you not get to
individual people to get on the same
page as far as what you know the final
end or these the highest good would be
you can't even get the same one person
over the course of time to do that and
he's got this wonderful passage where he
says that human beings you know what's
really driving us he says in the first
place I put for a general inclination of
all mankind a perpetual and restless
desire of power after power that seeketh
csis only in death why well when he
talks about power what he means there is
that which can get us what we want or
stave off what we don't want we're
talking about desire and aversion power
is what gets us what we desire and
there's a lot of different kinds of
power you know being able to read that's
a power the this capacity to produce
youtube videos another power the lights
that are shining down quite literally
power right and so power allows us to
get what we want and to not get or to
escape what we want against what we are
averse to so he says the cause of this
is not always that a man hopes for more
intensive delight than he's already
attained to or that it cannot be content
with moderate power but that he cannot
assure the power and means to live well
what you just saw there is a perfect
illustration of what I'm talking about
here in Hobbes you know we have some
unreliable lighting here shining down on
me and it went out and the same thing
can happen in our bodies it almost you
know fit the bill you might say so he
says you know the cause of this is not
always that a man hopes for more
intensive delight and he's already
attained to or that it cannot be content
with a moderate power but because he
cannot assure the power means to live
well
yes present without acquisition of more
we're constantly striving for more and
more and more we want to be secure we
want to ward off the things that were
averse to so we can never really be
content according to Hobbes you know he
says some other interesting things about
this as well he says a man's desire is
not to enjoy once and only for one
incident of time but to assure forever
the way of his future desire but we're
not really capable of doing that because
our future desires are in fact off in
the future they are changing as we're
going to see so he goes on and he says a
man cannot live whose desires are at an
end why because what it is to be alive
what it is to to exist as a living being
as the kind of beings that we are is to
be desiring and to be averse but because
our bodies are changing we're going into
new circumstances we desire different
things our desires and aversions altar
in their objects we've seen to that all
these passions come out of the desires
and aversions that means that we change
our minds and we change our feelings
about things now Hobbs is going to draw
out some very important corollaries to
this as well and I skipped over some of
the sections where he was talking about
these these different moral values or
distinctions these terms in the previous
video because I wanted to put them here
so that we could think about the
implications of the fact that our bodies
are changing and therefore our desires
and aversions are changing because that
means these things are going to be
changing as well which is a big issue a
big problem you might say for any sort
of common social life so what does all
this stuff over here me well you notice
that I've got the three basic effects of
desire or or love a version or hatred
and contempt and desire or love leads us
to seeing something is good what
is that we desire we see that as good
it's nothing it was good prior
necessarily to our desiring it's some
things we can cause to be good for us
just because of our desires for example
this piece of chalk very useful for me
right now isn't it because I can explain
things to you it's even a good thing for
you if insofar as you like seeing things
on the chalkboard but does this have any
intrinsic goodness in it no it's it's
only good because it's a useful thing we
wouldn't even say that it's delightful
or beautiful or anything like that so
when we desire something when we love
something when we see something under
the aspect of the good we call it good
and if we change our minds about what we
desire we're going to change our minds
about what is good so consider an
example is it good for you to be in
college right now I would assume most of
you would say yes those who change their
mind about it quit going to college or
they go to college and they're they're
continually griping about how they can't
wait to be finished and when they're
going to get on with their life and go
back to the real world and all that sort
of stuff that people tend to say when
their their discontent discontentment
like that comes about because our
desires change consider relationships
you're attracted to somebody that person
is attracted to you you go out on a few
dates now you get you know involved with
them and people say oh there are a
couple they're dating and then one of
you one day says I don't find you
attractive anymore and then the other
person says well that's not fair I still
find you attractive and you know this is
the stuff that movies are made of isn't
it and sappy songs but what that means
is what was good in the eyes of somebody
at one time has changed likewise what we
see as evil or bad can change over time
you know when you're a kid here's a
great example just they
tastes when you're a kid candy tastes
really good it continues to taste pretty
good as an adult but as you age
particularly if you're if you're a male
your tongue actually changes the
receptors in your tongue some of them
become stronger and some of them become
weaker think about beer I remember as a
kid you know taking a sip of my dad's
beer because you'd always send me to go
go get him a beer because he worked very
hard and you know would sit out on the
deck and I would get it and I took a sip
of it and I was like oh my goodness this
is awful how can anybody possibly drink
this I viewed it as something bad not
evil in a moral sense but something bad
something foul something unpleasant now
I like beer why do I like beer
particularly bitter beers like IPAs
because my taste receptors have changed
that's a matter of my body having
changed and therefore also my aversions
and desires having changed there's all
sorts of things like that we can talk
about you know fashion why don't we why
do we wear ties this is one of the
silliest things but it's part of you
know the you might say uniform of the
bourgeois or the academic or the
professional but you know what do you
think about it it's extremely silly how
can you get people to pay you know fifty
dollars or a hundred dollars for
something like this well you appeal to
their desires and if you change desires
into aversions you change things that
are good into things that are evil or
things that are bad there's also the
in-between that much we feel contempt
about that which we don't really care
about you know remember Hobbes says
things that we don't feel aversion or
desire towards its oftentimes because
we're feeling a version and desire to
other things we call contemptible we see
them as he says vial or in a
considerable vile doesn't mean evil in
this sense my I'll just make ah it's
nothing that I really care about its you
know our modern a term for that
would be me I don't care but if we go on
we see that Hobbes is developing a whole
moral vocabulary out of this as well
this is worth dwelling it so he talks
about things being good in three senses
and evil or bad in three senses he also
does a little bit of etymology there
which which probably doesn't make that
much sense to you but is you know nice
to think about at least a little bit he
says that whatsoever is the op the
object of man's the epitaph you desire
he calls good hater evil hate an
aversion evil contempt vile and
considerable these are used in relation
to the person who uses them there's
nothing in simply absolutely so and then
we can start to use these other things
he says the Latin tongue meaning you
know Latin has two words whose
significations approach to those of good
and evil but are not precisely the same
poll chram and Turpin and in greek these
would be cologne and ice thrown those
languages have a broader range of
signification when it comes to that than
we do so you know think about how we
could translate cologne or pull from
from Greek or Latin Hobbes gives us a
whole bunch of words that we use fair
not fair in the sense of you know being
fair to somebody but fair in the sense
of attractive fair in the sense of good
to look upon beautiful handsome
honourable comely amiable for terp I
he's got a great set of listing a list
of words here foul the form ugly base
nauseous and the like so he says in the
promise goodness in the promise when we
see something and we see it as beautiful
when we see it as attractive when we see
it as I'd like to get some of that we're
seeing goodness in the promise so think
about you know a tractive person the
promise there is something like boy if I
was going out with them I'd be going out
with a real
good looking person and I would I would
enjoy that we could talk about that in
terms of food though as well have you
ever looked at an advertisement and you
know you're kind of hungry and by the
end of the advertisement you're really
hungry and you're thinking man I should
go out and get something to eat you are
being actuated by those images that that
are helping you to to you know see
because of your desire that thing is
good in the promise it's going to be so
wonderful to sink my teeth into that
burger or lasagna or whatever in any
case good in the promise is what we call
you know fair or beautiful evil in the
province is what we call foul or
deformed or ugly or nauseous so that's
one modality good another modality is in
the effect when we we see something as
good we love it we desire it and then we
actually have it we get it we feel a
sense of delight or pleasure there's
nothing very you know tricky about this
you could multiply all sorts of examples
on the other hand when we don't like
something when we reverse to it and we
see it as bad and then we actually have
to endure it we see that as unpleasant
so you know you know poking yourself in
the face with a piece of poke yourself
in the eye with a piece of charm that's
going to be unpleasant you should be
averse to that we can think of all sorts
of other things as well so that's
another important modality the effect
and then he's got this discussion of
means there are many things that we see
is good or it is bad not because we see
them as good or bad in themselves not
because they provide us with pleasure or
pain in themselves or because they
promised us that sort of thing but
because they're a means to an end that
we either desire or we are averse to so
for example medicine you know nowadays
medicines all tastes pretty good but it
you know back in the day they used to
taste pretty bad before they figured out
that you could add all sorts of flavors
to them and we could talk about bitter
medicine it's not a lot of fun taking
medicine actually we could use another
example to antibiotics they may taste
good but they produce bad effects in our
our digestive system but they kill the
bacteria right they're good they're
useful they are helpful to us
entertaining what it is that we want
when we're sick not to be sick there's
all sorts of things that we desire as
means but we don't really want as n11
great example that would be money right
money by itself has no intrinsic value
it's only because we can exchange it for
the things that we really want the
opposite of that of course would be the
harmful that which is damaging to us
that which which you know maybe leads to
something that's unpleasant or something
that's foul or which takes away
something good now why did I go through
all of that what I wanted to stress to
you all of these distinctions all of
these senses you no-good evil fair
delightful useful foul unpleasant
harmful they're all coming because of
the play of desire and aversion now
desire and aversion for us human beings
don't remain the same why because a
human being is material and we are like
Hobbes says in our bodies in continual
motion in continual change in continual
flux that means that our desires don't
remain the same over time even if we try
to make them remain the same over time
that means that what we call good and
evil what we call beautiful and ugly
what we even call useful and harmful is
not going to be something that we can
rely upon and determine once and for all
it's going to be something that depends
on the person not only is beauty in the
eye of the beholder for Hobbes as is
ugliness but so is the useful so is the
harmful so is the good as such and so is
the bad as such it will vary according
to person to person to person so why is
this something that's going to lead us
into conflict if you see things in a
radically different way than I do and we
both want to get something done I may
see it as a good thing and you may see
it as a bad thing you and I may disagree
about what's beautiful and what's ugly
we may even disagree if we're trying to
talk about you know whether we should
build a ditch or you know repave a road
or raise taxes or lower taxes about what
are useful in what our harmful means so
there's a lot of potential because of
this change ability of human nature
there's a lot of potential for us to run
into conflict with each other and even
not to remain consistent with ourselves
to you might say my past self can enter
into conflict with my future self who is
going to see things in a very different
way so what is going to give us some
sort of solid set of moral conceptions
ultimately for Hobbes it's going to be
this thing that we're going to call the
social contract and that's where we
should leave off because that there's a
whole other video about that